this is the beginning of our fifth week
of shows from quarantine I'm excited
because tonight such a hilarious iconic
gentleman is going to be joining us
Martin Short Martin Short God he is
easily the ninth funniest person I know
on the west side of Los Angeles so
thrilled that he could be here and yeah
we're all looking for the silver linings
these days I know we're all in
quarantine this can be feeling like it's
getting old to some of you but I have to
tell you it is a beautiful day today
here in LA anyway absolutely gorgeous
weather this morning my kids asked if I
could take him to the beach and I said I
can't do that that's against the law now
we're not allowed to go to the beach but
I can recreate the beaches of LA here at
home so I did that I filled our bathtub
with water and garbage yeah zing take
that la beaches I win that round you may
have no speaking of kids you may have
noticed that a lot of hosts people love
this they're interrupted by their
children when they're doing the opening
of their show the children wander in and
and that hasn't been happening on my
show and that's because my kids hate me
they do not want to come in here they
want nothing to do with me
and I actually have noticed people like
it when kids wander in so I offered my
son two hundred and fifty dollars just
to wander in momentarily
he said not worth it who else is around
my wife my wife isn't here right now
my wife flew to Georgia to get her hair
done see how that works
yeah just read the news you'll see
that's very funny
well despite everything that's happening
people still want to know what's going
on in Hollywood so I'm gonna win our
eight hour news segment on the show
Hollywood buzz with our Hollywood
entertainment reporter Mario Lopez
hey Mario tell us what's going on in
Hollywood absolutely nothing
Conan thank you Mario
[Music]